the Panthers are looking for new
ownership Jerry Richardson gave up
control this has happened in the span of
well it felt like four days three days
that it went from there's something
going on here to now they're looking for
new ownership there and I'm not sure the
value of this team I don't know where
they look for new ownership how the
vetting process works but I wanted to
bring in Mike Florio Mike let me start
with this we know that the NFL was
investigating Jerry Richardson will they
continue to investigate these stories
charges even though Richardson will no
longer be there wait I thought when
Jerry Richardson decided he's just going
to fold the tent and sell the team that
would short-circuit this process it
makes it irrelevant he's voluntarily
doing what the worst-case scenario would
be based upon him on the investigation
but the league says they're still gonna
investigate he's given up day-to-day
control of the team and I have to wonder
whether he has a little remorse for
voluntarily walking away when he's still
going to get his name potentially
dragged through the mud
you know how these accommodations go
there's going to be fact to come out
it's been a Rivera set and at some point
he's gonna say why did I agree to sell
the team if you're going to do to me
what you would have done to me if I have
said no I'm not selling what's this team
worth whatever someone will pay for it
I mean I I love how Forbes tries to
value everything without the appropriate
access to the paperwork that would show
what the book value is and then
regardless what the book value is it's
what someone will pay for it yeah so
you're gonna have loops lined up without
it and I just like a sound record I'm
not interested in buying the Carolina
Panthers because I think that's now the
thing to do but yet you or I am
interested because what the hell let's
just put some money together and buy the
team but what you have to have at least
one person and I think the minimum is
30% that one person has to actually be
able to buy physically not with debt but
here's money that I'm gonna buy and own
this team list you put your group
together and there's gonna be bids we
saw it with the bills four years ago
Donald Trump was one of the bidders John
Bongiovi had a group and whoever bids
the most is going to get the team and I
know a few numbers like 2.5 billion oh
yes work at this point it's whatever
someone will pay and the best leverage
you have
if you're gonna sell something is to say
screw it I'm just not going to sell what
you're Richardson doesn't have that
Lefferts he's definitely selling and
that could end up being a factor too and
with the final price tag yes but the
vetting process now for the NFL
considering the climate here and
replacing an owner accused of these you
know sexual harassment charges how does
it change and and what does that do to
the number of candidates here hey that's
an excellent point because now the
stakes are raised and what else is out
there that you don't know about what
other tough questions do you need to ask
and going back to what brought down
Richardson the fact that there were at
least four situations where there was a
settlement with a former employee who
made some sort of a claim well it's
standard practice in American business
to enter into settlement agreements with
disgruntled former employees they get
upset they go see a lawyer the lawyer
identifies the potential claims they
could make you make a few phone calls
you write a few letters and the next
thing you know there's a settlement that
doesn't mean anybody did anything and
that's a slippery slope for the enough
whether it's vetting new owners or
whether it's going through the files of
the other 31 current owners and looking
for any other times where someone has
paid out money to make a sexual
harassment claim go away even if there
was no merit to it whatsoever so this is
a new frontier for the NFL I hope they
understand what they're venturing into
as it relates to bet alone there's as
relates to holding your breath and
waiting for the next shoe to drop on
whichever owner owner out there has four
or five or six or ten or however many
settlement agreements have been paid out
to former employees over the years he's
Mike Florio from pro football talk also
NBC Sports Network the Aaron Rodgers
status for this game coming up who's
making this call in your opinion what I
think ultimately will be a doctor
decision a medical decision but you know
Rodgers has to be a factor in all of
this he said originally if I'm healthy
and if it makes sense I'll come back
well no longer makes sense they lost
they're out of the playoffs and I think
yesterday when they signed Joe Callahan
back to the roster that was but that was
the clue even though they didn't get
knocked out of the playoffs until last
night anymore
and came back that means robbers is
gonna play and I think Rogers is still
dealing with that Brett Farr spectre
that you know Brett Favre showed up
every game play every game I have to be
perceived as tough like Brett Favre and
I don't think he's ever going to be the
one to say I'm tapping out it's got to
be the doctor that says you know in
light of the status of the injury and in
light of all the hips he took on on
Sunday it's it's in his best interest
not to play and Rodgers will say all the
right things and I'm not criticizing for
it I'm just saying I'm just predicting
how it's going to go Rodgers are going
to say who wants to play and someone
from the team is going to say you're
allowed to play my good stuff I'll see
you over the weekend all right that's
Mike Florio from pro football talk for
more Dan Patrick show to the audience
channel 239 on DirecTV or download the
Dan Patrick show at
[Music]